considered that further restriction of
the working hours would not be
reasonable
to be imposed and it would not meet the
six tests
with regards to the provision of a an
improved
footpath along hebrews creek
which was another discussion along here
it is noted that although
there is an informal footpath around the
runs along hebrews creek this is not a
public right of way
officers have assessed this matter and
consider that his
planning obligation that a planning
obligation securing
improvements of the food path would go
beyond what is reasonably uh related to
the scale and kind of the proposed
development and therefore it would not
meet the three tests for planning
obligations
however
it is considered that necessary that
sufficient and safe pedestrian link is
provided
between the site and the existing
network for that reason a grumping
condition for the provision of an
extended um food bath that links the
site
with the um existing
foodway cycleway along aldi which is
here
is secured through the grampian
condition
so
in light of what's been already
addressed officers recommend approval of
the application subject to conditions
imposed to the
updated report
submitted for the application and
obviously the planning obligation um for
the monitoring of the travel plan
thank you chairman thank you
members
i will open the floor i've got one
question that i'd like to ask and that
actually relates to
landscaping
which i read in your report was
a reserve matter
does that mean that that will be decided
by the department on and you as the
officer or will that come back to this
committee
through determine a reserve matters
application will have to be submitted to
assess matters in relation to
landscaping and appearance of the
buildings
and
this is an application that members
could call in to committee um so yes it
could be decided either by under
delegated powers or by a committee thank
you um
councillor spenceley
thank you chairman
so in relation to condition six which is
also on the members update five um
5.19 and 5.110
regarding the grampian condition for the
pedestrian and cycle route having
visited the site it became clear that it
was even more important than we'd
realized potentially with the danger to
pedestrians or cyclists trying to access
the site without that facility there as
well as of course the sustainable
transport um which we'd like to
encourage
um i i noticed that the applicant is
still resisting that so obviously i'd
really like that to be noted that is
absolutely going to happen as a part of
the grampian condition
but also noting the enforcement that's
needed for the pathway that runs down
the side of aldi and i would like um
just to say to officers could we please
have that enforced at the earliest
opportunity otherwise having the new um
having the grampian condition in paris
will be meaningless
so i just just would like that noted
please come back
michael yep thank you thank you chair uh
just to say that that is
noted
you want anything else
yeah through determine the grampian
condition is there to secure that it
will be provided prior to the
commencement so
yeah
and michael already noted the matter
about enforcement thank you councillor
beal
thank you chair um looking at that plan
am i right that the south easterly side
is where all of these lorries are going
to be coming in and out
yeah
through you determine um
the re the access to the side is through
here so part of the
activity yeah part of the activity will
be on this side but also part of the
activity will be going down here yes
there are two turning facilities
down here
well that's what i'm worried about
because if those buildings had been
turned round
like all of the other buildings on that
site which were facing internally
we wouldn't have had all the issue with
the noise
you've got all the noise coming from the
lorries and everything else directly
over to wharf
is it wolf road yeah yes over to walk
road
it's not going to be such an issue now
for uh battle battle rise
but
to me they've been laid out wrong
it's just something i've noticed
practically then building should have
been manipulated round so that like all
of the other buildings on that site
all of the walls were to the to the
creek
and i mean i know we can't change it now
but to me it's just wrong
yeah
if i can go back through your tournament
and there is a reason why it's been laid
out this way and the reason is that the
environment agency has requested a 20
meter gap
from the
defenses so they can have access in the
future if need be to do maintenance
works so that land that that is um
the
hatched area i don't know if you can see
that that should remain clear from
buildings that's why it's been laid out
this way but coming back that's
basically causing the issue
because of the way that they've insist i
mean i know that it's the environment
agency and i did ask the guy who was
showing us around why is it like this
and he said because
i said how did the environment agency
maintain that sea wall
and his answer was they come on site
so that's why it's been done like that
but you don't need 20 meters to get a
lorry in
to maintain a sea wall
but basically those buildings are
orientated the wrong way if all of them
the long wall had been
this way
and the same with that turned round so
it was facing the other entrance
it's just all wrong it's created the
problem
but said we've got to decide on this
application on what they've put forward
yes you can yes it is yes
just a reminder that um the site is
already used as open storage when we
visited the site
this area down here um was uh
it did have loads of materials stored at
present lorries
and another machinery can go down here
and store materials in that area because
it has a lawful use as open storage
and
and
storage and distribution so it is used
already for those purposes and
and the lawful operational hours is 24
7. that's just a reminder
i know what you're saying um basically
they have actually put in a noise report
and as you said they are dealing 24 7 at
the minute
but we were worried about the noise
um and as i said
if anyone had half a brain they would
have turned those buildings around and
probably still had their 20 meters that
they insisted on
and it would have
reduced any noise it would have reduced
it more than what it is now
yes sir
thank you um that's just fine
thank you
chairman just to clarify a couple of
these points we've just
covered and this grampian condition
actually depends upon
the district council doing something
effectively
rather than aldi
yes
through determine no it's uh the
developer the applicant who would have
to form the footpath prior to the
commencement of the development you
can't do anything yeah including the ld
bit that's a separate matter this is a
matter for reinforcement this is this is
outside the um
the determination of the karen
application i'll be entirely on the
carriageway owned by the yes
okay now on this question of ours
um we've said they actually operate 24
hours currently but that is going to be
restricted to 11 o'clock under
i understand the layout and i i think um
uh should we say one we should accord
the environment agency the full width
that it really wants because um
maintaining them developing this
sea wall is going to be extremely
important
um there's another point about
illumination um i think was condition
19. it said something about no external
illumination
but surely um there has to be external
elimination for during the working hours
yeah
um three determine you need to consider
that the site is um located adjacent to
nature conservation sites
and we would need to protect
species that they live in those areas so
the a lighting scheme would have to be
submitted to and approved in writing it
would just need to be sensitive
for the species yeah yes but obviously
it would still be lighting for working
out yes
yes um the
more important issue is on this question
of archaeological investigation
um and i think there's a fairly strong
condition in there about um doing some
ground works
uh some uh
trial and
trial works for
assessing the um so it is a bit more
than a desk exercise um is it possible
to um
add
something which i think is
down there on one of the informatives
relating to something else
about
pollution or about contamination
in other words that um
the
the developer should report anything
found during the course of the
development work
that is say in addition to anything that
stands as a sort of trial
trial decks beforehand
condition um
30 and 31
relate to the assessment prior to
development
for the archaeological page
1331 yeah
yes
of course yeah through determine yeah
you've there are two conditions about
archaeology as has been stated um
normally if
the environmental health officers have
um
records of
contamination or pollution they do
require a condition for contamination to
be imposed in this instance it was just
requested to be an informative so if
something is identified
yeah yes but my question is can we have
a similar
condition
informative relating to anything
archaeologically found during the
works that would have to be
the two conditions imposed in relation
to archaeology
means that they if if something's been
found they will have to
notify the heritage people in essex
county council so he is part of their
part of the condition yeah yeah it does
like that
yeah so when they do the work see if
they find anything they need to notify
yeah it's covered in the condition
finally chairman um
5210 does point out the the rudimentary
and utilitarian style of the buildings
which is very sad when you think of the
vast roof area that's there which
probably won't have any solar panels or
anything is this something we can take
up at the
detail planning stage
no
yeah three determine we at the moment
don't have a policy um our policies is
silent in relation to renewable energy
on proposed buildings
it would be positive if it would be
added but it
it would be up to the applicant to
decide whether they want to install uh
solar panels into the roof yeah
we can't we can't they're they have
they could be positive energy positive
of course but we we can't even condition
for that um unfortunately
thank you thank you i mean i mean i'll
just add and it's probably pretty
standard that um there are uh certain
you know energy and carbon requirements
that would have to be satisfied but
that's through building control
yes of course thank you
members um
councillor again
thanks jeff um just a couple of
questions points really because i can't
vote on it because i couldn't get the
time to to go to the place although i
know where it is you mentioned because i
can't get past noise
yeah so you mentioned that you know you
just considered that the the impact of
noise will not be negative i can't
remember the the planning led wording
that you used it's an open space at the
moment my question is when it's a
building how do you know what models
were used
because at the moment we're not
measuring eggs with eggs and as um
councilor bill has said with the with
the buildings being turned around and
their sides are going to be up
you're going to get reverberation you're
going to get more machinery in there
you're going to get a lot more noise and
i think you said it wouldn't be
reasonable
to me it just seems counterintuitive
that it would be reasonable to to have
some sort of noise attenuation system in
place because it's going to go across
because water makes things travel as
well
so i'm just flummoxed by the fact that
we can't say and it'll be in a
reasonable way that we should be able to
put something in there because at the
moment you've got a nice big flat open
area and then you're going to put a lot
of buildings on it
it doesn't make sense the reverberation
yes of course
through determining um
the noise report that's the report
that's been submitted with the
application
considered the worst case scenarios
the existing use of the site is b8
storage and distribution but is open the
proposed use of the site is b8 storage
and distribution contained within
buildings
and so effectively what's been
raised within the noise assessment and
the environmental health officer is that
actually the noise is going to be
contained within the building rather
than being in the open
and
so
that's that's why it's been considered
that is is unreasonable to add a
condition for um acoustically designed
um units
yeah of course what's um what are those
readings
what are those readings
so you said the readings that that were
considered the noise that levels were
gonna get would be considered so what
were the noise levels i mean is that how
how do you do that you model that in a
specific way
because it is going to be noisy no
matter what we sit here and say and it's
going to impact on people and i know
it's an industrial state so i'm aware of
that
through your ceremony obviously i'm not
the expert in i'm not a noise consultant
but
um
to give you an idea as to how this has
been assessed uh weakens they consider
the existing background noise and onto
that they add the noise generated by the
proposed use
i mean when it's going to be built so
they found out that the noise levels
would not increase higher
to than the existing background noise
to an extent that it would require uh
mitigation measures that's how it's been
assessed obviously the exact readings
numbers
yeah the noise report is it's been
submitted and is on the public domain
can i
double just your attention also to
condition 17
um no external plant or machinery shall
be used unless and until details of the
equipment have been submitted to and
approved by the local planning authority
any measures required by the local
planning authority to reduce noise
from the plant or equipment shall be
completed prior to the plant being
bought into use and retained
there thereafter
so effectively obviously any equipment
that they're going to be used that might
have a sound implication because it's
mechanical electrical will have to be
subject to an assessment and where
mitigation is appropriate sorry
especially noise levels and how they're
traveling will have to be agreed and
approved by us
thank you
um going on from uh councillor lagan um
i i understand exactly where you're
coming from um we can condition my only
concern is that this could be
um appealed against
and obviously i need to make the point
that if we then
uh don't succeed in upholding
our position
then there may be costs um that are
involved with that so as long as we know
what we're letting ourselves in for if
members
want to condition
we can do that
i'll come back to you um
councillor stilts
thank you like councillor lagan i can't
vote on this but i do have one question
you're saying that the
noise from this factory when it's built
will be no different to the noise that's
there now
what are the hours that they're working
now because they're going to be working
longer hours when this factory is built
no
yes carry on
to determine they have lawful
operational hours the current
operational hours are 24 7. they
proposed are seven till 11.
so it's they're going to be reduced no
nighttime operation
is it a new
question um it was just a comment on
this question of noise
which i hadn't mentioned and i unders i
accept what council lagging says about
what noise traveling over water but the
combination of
working inside and limited hours would
seem to me that the noise level may
actually be less
like yeah it could be cats like and did
you want to come back at all yeah no
thanks i mean it's all it's all valid
debate but the only comment i say about
conditioning i said that's our job isn't
it as members we're supposed to change
course yeah you know you see if you roll
over and go oh too scared to do all of
that what are we doing here
no if you want to make a a
recommendation then then that's fine
what i'll do
madam chairman is because what mr
johnson said
gives me a little bit of surety that the
noise is not going to be as bad and
that's been thought of
but it's on record that i'm still
concerned about the level of noise and
impact yeah i too am concerned about it
and i think
um we have been through that
um do i have a um any other sorry
councillor beal
yeah sorry i think the uh the answers in
the drawing if those buildings were
round so that the the back walls were
facing the creek you wouldn't have any
issue with noise at all because it would
all be internal into the site
so
whichever way i go it's purely on the
orientation of the buildings members um
the proposal is um to uh approve this
application
with the 31 conditions that are nine
informatives that we already have
um which included the archaeological
ones which was much stronger than it was
originally
um i'm going to make the proposal to it
to approve this
application do i have a
uh councillor swain thank you can we now
go to the vote all those in favor
one two three
that's three
and all those against
and one against could that be recorded
as three four
and one against and i've abstained
thank you
thank you members
are you um okay to run
perfect
we now move
uh yes sorry yes uh that that is
carried thank you
we now move to item 6
application 22
0 603
102 b and 102 c high street moulding
found on pages 51 to 62.
there were also supplementary papers
that were circulated yesterday i think
it was just a single page from memory
this has come to committee uh as the
application was called in by councillor
um swain on the grounds of concerns in
relation to policy d1 and e2
um
we moved to uh the officer who is miss
boles
could you present your report please
thank you chair thank you and planning
permission is sought for the change of
use of an existing retail unit to merge
with the unit next door to create one
restaurant and to replace the frontage
of both units
so here's the location plan
and this is the existing floor plan this
is the
high street frontage here
and this is a proposed floor plan and as
you can see
the two units will be merged
these are the existing elevations um the
application is a retrospective one and
the elevations are now not as shown
this was the existing front elevation
with the two units shown
this is the proposed front elevation um
which is what
is now in the high street is set for the
uh the sign
and these are the proposed elevations
here's the rear with the two windows
that are going to be blocked up and the
duct and flu
that are going to be added
this is what is currently um on the high
street without the
salt name above it
this is a rear elevation currently
view from the high street to the rear
and a view from the rear of the site to
neighbouring property
and the change of use of the retail unit
to a restaurant is considered acceptable
in principle particularly having regard
to the fallback position which confirms
that the proposed change of use could be
undertaken without the need for planning
permission
further is not considered to have a
detrimental impact on the function
vitality or viability of the
primary retail function of the area the
impact on the neighbouring residential
properties can be minima minimized to an
acceptable level by conditions and the
external changes to the front are
considered acceptable and are not
considered to be detrimental to the
conservation area
therefore the application is recommended
for approve
thank you
excellent
we have one public participant for this
item mr cumbers the agent mr cumbers i'd
like to invite you to come forward
please take a seat
and turn on your microphone please
are you okay with that
okay um i'd like to remind you you've
got two minutes um for your submission
okay good evening um i'd like to bring a
few points to the committee's attention
uh the shop unit 102c
uh formerly occupied by morgan discount
has been empty for over two years and
before the applicant took over the
building there'd be no interest for any
commercial use
there are also many other empty shops in
the high street
this is a sign not only the rise of
internet shopping
but also
three large supermarkets around walton
bypass
all with free car parking and drawing
shops away from the town centre
i accept that moulton was a market town
as strategy team suggests
but where is the town market
they also suggest that proposals have
design cues of a seaside resort
however the proposal is for a family
restaurant
there is no intention for off sales of
food or drink
and certainly no buttocks and spades as
the previous shot morgan discount used
to sell
both the strategy team and the town
council criticized the shop front as
being
characteristic of the conservation area
however the council's conservation
officer has stated that the shop front
is an improvement on the previous
situation
and results in no further harm to the
consulate conservation area
the applicant has tried to move forward
his opening date to enable him to
recover some of the financial outlay
in renovating and improving this
building
and provide a smart specialist pizza
restaurant
ask the members to support his efforts
and this application thank you
thank you very much mr cumbers
okay members um i'm going to open um to
to discussions i'd i'd like to actually
come to uh councillor swain first of all
please
and
yes thank you chairman um there are a
number of points and obviously
i think we must all be puzzled by this
fact that planning permission doesn't
seem to be needed in which case one
wonders what we're doing here
um and just what we are but i mean there
are
a number of points to be said uh
assuming i'll get an answer on that
um about um
which i suppose is what has meant by the
fallback position
um
to take the
whether the three aspects one is on this
design and um i note in the papers the
officers point out that it's undesirable
to have such a long frontage of three
units it's turned i mean apparently this
is three units and the fact that you've
got the other sark next door i don't
think is any argument in favor of
another long frontage
um
which is one negative which the officers
point out
um
they're quite keen to say that one
change
isn't
significant in the total high street but
the point is that the high street
the vitality of the high street depends
upon the range of offer
diversification so
there is a danger of it becoming
um ceasing to be a proper high street if
if one has
this expansion
and therefore um
[Music]
i'm against this
should we say loss of a retail premises
that has been used as an argument by the
officers on a number of other cases for
refusing applications
of the loss of retail outlets and and
now it's um being as we say eli did in
this um
incident
um if i could prefer to the application
is to
change from
e sub section a to e
class b
subsection b
um and e specifically excludes um pot
food
b
simply says that is for food and drink
principally to visiting members of the
public
when consumption food and drink is
mainly undertaken on premises
um i can't i can't see how this will not
lead to
um
takeaways of some sort and i wonder how
we would monitor
mainly eaten on the premises to
partially eaten on the premises um so i
think there was this um
this risk of of parking and picking up
food
and prepared meals or whatever
which is what
we've used as a argument against um one
or two other
um
situations
um i'd just like to mention this um
question about the noise and
smells that would be generated by
being a restaurant and therefore
producing much more hot food and so on
um
the the
neighboring the neighbors to this
are in fact not next door they're above
this property and it's difficult to see
how they would not
be impacted by noise and smells coming
from down below on a extended house
period
so
overall um
i think
as i think the officers might admit it's
a balanced decision but i it seems to me
that this loss of
the the design factor the loss of retal
um
premises is a strong
argument for um refusing the application
thank you
councillor lagan
thank you and
madam chair i'm quite fond of buckets in
space do like going down there but um i
get the point um
i have a major disappointment this is a
retrospective application i agree you
know they've charged ahead and started
work and then it's coming to us to make
a decision but
with a high street whether i like it or
not is immaterial it's as i scrutinize
d1 and e2 to have a look and see you
know does it does it work or does it not
and i couldn't find anything that i
could actually hook on to say that it's
definitely not something that should be
allowed and high streets
i've known the high street all my life
because i was born here and they all
evolve
you know and we used to have loads of
estate agents and you know we have
nail bars and we'd have we've got heaps
of restaurants and in 25 years time we
might have we'll have something
completely different
and um
the the modern discount did stay empty
for a long time and didn't look it was a
gordy yellow sort of shop front
so from from a perspective of you know
the employment that it's going to bring
the offer that it's going to bring and
the way that it looks
i
particularly don't have a problem
supporting the recommendation from the
officer um although clearly that should
be caveated that this is you know very
very disappointed it's come as a
retrospective application
absolutely thank you
um councillor edwards and then
councillor stilts
thank you chairman um first of all i
have to agree with cancer language
this unit or the one on the left has
been empty for some time
if we wanted retail companies to come in
there they haven't approached us so
blast doesn't exist and secondly and he
already pointed out it will produce
employment in the town and that's what
we need thank you
councillor steltz
thank you i've got a couple of questions
if we can go to the picture of the
inside of the store
so
it's not going to be a takeaway but
we've got a separate bit doing pizza
area or is that going to be just serving
pizzas in that area
yes yes of course and there's no detail
regarding where they're going to serve
pizzas but
um
having been in pizza restaurants a pizza
oven can be quite spectacular to see and
it
may well be that it's out on the shop
floor so that people can see the pizzas
cooking it just made me wonder if we're
saying there's no takeaway why that that
area is separate to the other area that
was all um
and the other third question i'm going
to ask is about this noise objection
from environmental health
because of the flats above
have we asked i know we're going to ask
that
an assessment should be undertaken and
submitted are we going to ask for that
before that we have done with other
establishments in the town
yes miss pearls oh sorry mr johnson
thank you chairman yes um i i do believe
um and miss mrs boles can correct me
that the submission of the details and
their clearance would be before
well
the condition is actually not quite
clear when i when i looked at this um
fairly recently but it can be tweaked to
ensure that you know before trading or
before the opening of the premises that
and in fact it would be necessary to do
that in order to ensure that the
appropriate mitigation is in place
so that that can be that can be easily
covered through the conditions are we
also going to go through odor as well
yes yes
thank you
um the news class
um you questioned regarding takeaway
takeaways are a separate use class so
they will not be able to
run a takeaway from
the restaurant that that would be
enforceable or they would have to put in
an application for permission to do so
would you like to come back and say so
what is the force of the wording then
that is mainly eaten on the premises
sort of those implies that some is not
even on
would be permissible to be not eaten on
the premises
i don't know i think yeah yeah
english
but when it comes to course
i think um we can we we need to just
make sure that our conditions are very
tight that takeaways are not allowed to
be um
operated um
chris could you turn your yeah thank you
the the takeaway use is a separate use
it does come under class f and therefore
they cannot use it as a takeaway
okay counselor still cancel oh
no hold on i've gone to cancer sales i
will come back to you
counselor students thank you it's just a
quick question looking at the drawings
there and it was something that
that shows
three door openings
and there's only actually one on the
shop front
these two here are the openings that are
going to be blocked up they're in dotted
lines
is that okay thank you
mr johnson
thank you chairman just um just a
just back onto the sort of used glass
issue here
um
and the fallback position the full back
position is that
under the current use class glasses
order which was amended in
august 2020
from the old style which used to include
class a1 a2 a3 a4 and a5 yes
the a-class the a-class
of the old order pre-august 2020
has been rescinded
and they're now all been amalgamated
under class e
class e includes um
class a1 a2 and a3 of the old classes
order
class uh a4 and a5 specifically related
to
um pubs and and wine bars and class a
five was takeaways yeah
now you explicitly need planning
permission for those two uses yeah uh so
so so so there is no fallback in terms
of takeaways and pubs and and pubs and
uh and wine bars and things and things
things things of the of of that nature
now under this application the applicant
has applied for
um a restaurant a restaurant would would
would have fallen under the used classes
or the old used glass is all done the a3
it is now within class a1
so this application
by its very description is one that
would fall within the the a3 that
prohibits um a takeaway element
um but it is within members gift if they
so wish to have a condition to sort belt
and braces yeah that there should be no
takeaway elements but that's explicit
within what this application has been
applied for
i'm just gonna there's a couple of other
points you you made you made reference
to cancer swain in in terms of
of of the flu
um there there are conditions and the
council still make mention to that as
well there are some conditions in terms
of details for the flu to to control
um uh
well principally the older but also
in relation to upper floors and this is
quite standard right across most
planning authorities the control of
vibrations yeah so normally if a fluid
is attached to a wall there'd be you
know anti-vibration mounts and that sort
of things the flue must uh extend above
the ease or above you know the
highest point on any building of which
there is a residential window so it
would discharge upwards into the air
yeah
so these are the things that in the
submission of any detail we'd be looking
to be satisfied um and that must be
clear that must be agreed with us before
the development can actually commence
well in this sense is retrospective but
before the use itself can commence or
before trading again it's within our
gift just to be quite specific in terms
of those particular conditions
um
you mentioned the shop front
um
and
the
you know the fact that there is
you know it's contrary to
e2 i mean there is flexibility within e2
and i'll just draw um members attention
also
to the fact that there was uh
an appeal decision in 2019
on 102
c i think yep 102c yes um
and within that appeal decision quite
early on the inspector specifically
noted that the local planning authority
had no objection against the change of
use
from retail to a3 now this was before
the change in the used classes order
yeah just to be clear
the inspector explicitly said he has no
reason
um to um to disagree with the council's
position in that
if the inspector had reason he could
again through the legislation bring that
into a consideration he chose not to do
that
um
he recognized also in terms of what that
would have meant in terms of the um
shop front or the retail frontage within
the within the town center and also in
terms of its design which sort of links
into the whole design issue as well the
inspector refused that appeal strictly
in terms of the shop front design as it
was at the time
which because it did not include glazing
bars and and specifically vertical
glazing bars we can see by this design
here that you know it's it's it's
principally i mean the photograph shows
exactly how it is it is principally one
of of glazing bars which which fits in
with the character of the street okay
the materials are different but in terms
of the general rhythm so materials are
not different they were originally
uh metal but they are still metal okay
right yeah so so either way it kind of
it keeps him with it with the character
obviously in a broad sense yeah because
it's a modern building it fits in with
the character of the general rhythm
within the high street so again those
are reasons why officers support support
this scheme i mean we're not looking for
light for light but we're looking for a
rhythm and we're looking for something
which is sympathetic doesn't necessarily
mean it has to be identical
i think those are the points i've
covered thank you thank you um i think i
think you've actually had a
quite a good explanation as to where we
sit on that i'd like to go to other
members first and also i've got a
question
about the noise
impact
especially in relation to air
conditioning units which i know
but i don't remember seeing anything in
the report about air conditioning units
disposed through you check there is um a
condition regarding any other external
plant or machinery that will be
installed all the details of the
equipment have to be submitted and
approved by the local planning authority
okay thank you um i'll now come to
councillor lagan and then uh councillor
stilts and then councillor beal actually
i'll go no i'm actually going to go to
council bill first because councilman
hasn't spoken on this matter
that makes a change
right i'm not sure this is a point of
order but i'd like clarification on what
we should actually call the chair
because everyone's calling you chairman
at the minute that's fine i'm quite
happy with that i mean i i've i've been
calling your chair but and i'm quite
happy with you calling me that as well i
don't have a particular preference
either which way
thank you
thank you i'm just noting
that out of the four consultees that
we've got
replies from three out of the four have
objected to it
and i can't believe the conservation
officer says it's absolutely wonderful
obviously she borrowed a pair of my
glasses i reckon um and there's no doubt
at all
that we are definitely
not going to go hungry in malden no i
don't think i mean you know the
percentage of
places to get somewhere do we if you can
afford it is
a little bit ott
yeah i think the conservation officer
actually said that it was an improvement
on what was there before
um and more along the lines that he
actually wanted
um
thank you councillor lagan
yeah thanks yeah you can counselor
bill's right you're not going to go
hungry because it's just the evolution
of the town at the moment isn't it so um
i was this is a slight um
diversion from what we're debating but
um mr johnson kindly sort of said he was
when i give to condition no takeaways i
can't see why on earth we would put that
condition in when so many other places
have that joint facility and sarc i
believe does the same so
it worried me a little bit that we might
be containing the opportunity for
someone to expand their business
irrespective of how i personally feel
about the look and the way it was done
personally i would i'd like to see you
know this business take off be
successful and then put an application
in separately for a takeaway if that's
what they want to do i don't want to cut
them off now
and i think that will be morally and
fundamentally the wrong thing to do
uh yeah well i think i think it's quite
clear that that uh in the class
you can't be a takeaway and that if you
want to be a takeaway you've got to
apply for a separate permission and to
condition for it i think is unnecessary
it doesn't meet the standards um that
that we have to if you're going to
condition
um so yeah i think you've got a good
point there um councillor stilts
i was actually going to say almost the
same as councillor lagan i think it
would be
um
detrimental to these people the fact
that they would be the probably the only
non-takeaway in the high street um so
you know to to actually put that
condition in i think would be wrong but
if we can go to the
uh view of the back
um on your pictures that one
are we going to be assured that
unit which is a refrigerated unit is
actually going to go
mr johnson
thank you
thank you chair chair chairman
um
there is there is an open enforcement
case um i'm sure the agent is uh pretty
much aware that um the enforcement team
have
had very consistent and up to fairly
recent communications with his client uh
in terms of the enforcement matters so
we're very much on it um
[Music]
awaiting the outcome of this application
is obviously all part of that but but
specifically um to addressing the
refrigeration unit
um which is not part of the application
of this confirmed now it's not part of
the application it's a matter of that
that that will need to be addressed
thank you thank you mr johnson
um i will come back um to mr uh sorry
cancer councillor um spain thank you
madam chairman um
stop here
yes i'd just like to
mention one point you've made in there
that although it's been mentioned at the
places discount been empty for
a long time um the the point has been
made in the papers that
there's no proof that it's actually been
advertised
for sufficient length of time as an
available retail unit
maybe that does exist but it's obviously
that this hasn't been provided to the
the officers
on the second point kept following on to
what
mr johnson's been um
discoursing on i think it would be very
very helpful to
members to know just what the scope is
for moving within class e
between the sub sections maybe that's a
training opportunity
yeah i'll take that on as a as a
training opportunity thank you um uh
councillor spain members um there is uh
a recommendation to approve this
application subject to eight conditions
and one informative um i propose that
this application is approved do i have a
secondar
thank you councillor lagann
um
mrs bowles can you um go through the
condition about the flu and to ensure
that that is a strong enough condition
particularly in relation to the um
uh residential
properties above yes i think there's is
there two flats above i think it's two
plants
which was two flats
i will
make it prior to
um
yeah
i shall make it prior to
the business commencing
the noise and the odor um
attenuation mitigation
will
will um need to be approved by the
council
that's sufficient isn't it mr johnson
yeah that's lovely um okay so i have a
um a proposal i have a second uh can we
take a vote on this all those in favor
two three four five
five four
uh those against
two against
any abstentions
me
uh thank you uh that's carried
five two two
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
um i appreciate your time on this
i moved to item
seven uh any other business of the by
the chairman of the committee decides
this urgent no i don't have any
thank you very much i close this meeting
at 8
25.